Alexis Rodda:
(singing) Cry, little child, cry. Cry, little child, cry.
(singing) Cry with the abundance of hope God has given.
Alexis Rodda:
(singing) Cry with the harsh knowledge of your mortality.
(singing) Cry, my baby, cry. Cry, my baby, cry.
Alexis Rodda:
(singing) Cry until your mother sings you asleep...
(chorus sings)
Max Mamon:
Hi, I'm Max Mamon, and I'm a senior. I am the composer of "Rosaleen." "Rosaleen" is a nice mix of arias.
There's some spoken dialogue. The style is kind of a mix of opera from the 20th century,
Max Mamon:
and art song with some pop influences.
cast:
(singing) Let not this flower fade. Hear my mute appeal. Let not this flower fade. Hear my mute appeal.
(singing) If love can sustain...
Alexis Rodda:
Rosaleen is a Victorian woman in New England who is highly educated for her day, but ends up
unfortunately encountering tragedy. And even though she attempts to be a modern woman,
Alexis Rodda:
she actually is a interesting mix of Victorian and modern, because through her inability to
mother a child ends up going mad. So, even though she tries to challenge some feminine
Alexis Rodda:
stereotypes, she also falls into some of those stereotypes herself.
cast:
(singing) Love! Love! We're yearning for love.
Casey Ford Alexander:
Hi, I'm Casey Ford Alexander, Class of 2010.
Vivian DeWoskin:
Hi, I'm Vivian DeWoskin, Class of 2011.
Casey Ford Alexander:
In "Rosaleen," we have to do a series of dances throughout the piece.
cast:
(singing)
Casey Ford Alexander:
A lot of the inspiration comes from Victorian dance.
Vivian DeWoskin:
Group dances.
Casey Ford Alexander:
And it's pretty cool. Whether there are happy scenes or sad scenes, I think Alexis has done
a really good job of making dances that are appropriate for whatever the mood is.
cast:
(singing) Cry, little child, cry. Cry, little child, cry. Cry until your mother sings you asleep.